[Music]
[Applause]
patrick ewing had a good weekend
had a good four days four wins four days
dust off creighton win the big east and
now
in the tournament as a number 12 see
they play colorado on saturday
and the georgetown head coach patrick
ewing my hoya is joining us on the
program
coach how much celebrating did you do
after the win on saturday
first of all dan it's always great to be
on
um we celebrated a lot in the locker
room
on the bus ride back to the hotel uh
stayed up a little bit uh i know that uh
my players
they probably stayed up the whole night
talking some of them
they took they took turns uh taking the
the trophy to their to their room
i know they left me i took the ball with
me in in one of the nets
so because i'm gonna get that put in my
office
um but we had a great uh
night uh of celebration and you know to
for what we have accomplished but you
know which we're
we're saving the the entire the rest of
the celebration hopefully
when we get to the end of this road did
it dawn on you as you're up on the
ladder cutting down that
net that you did that as a 19 year old
in the
same building you know i really
i didn't think about it the only thing i
thought about was that
you know someone told me that on that
night
with that night was the night that coach
thompson
uh got hired at georgetown you know 49
years ago
so that made it uh even more special
uh to see how far we have come
from him being the coach there
on on that day and then fast forward all
those
decades later uh to us and me
being uh one of well the first
to win it as a player and as a coach
you got that uh coach's postseason voice
that's a good thing you know
it was it was a lot worse um on saturday
it's starting to get a little better now
you know my players are like
i can't hear you well they might say
that to you
you know at other times during this
coach i couldn't hear what you were
saying
yeah you know some it could be good and
bad
what was the pregame speech like before
you played creighton
uh you know all i would say
before we came before we came to new
york we kept talking about taking steps
um it has been a trying year for not
only us but everyone
in every sport uh shutdowns
you know covered people getting sick all
that
all those different things but once we
got locked in and
you know we just talked about taking
steps you know it was funny
leading up to the big east tournament we
had some terrible practices
so i'm like oh my goodness you know
we're going to show up and not
even uh compete but they they locked in
they took the steps that was needed
they came prepared and they came ready
and uh we got the job done
i i don't know if i'm reading too much
into this i did text you after
the game but the security issue when you
show up and they're
checking to see your credential uh or
asking for your credential
um did your team rally around that like
did they know
what happened um they were there for the
first
time i got stopped uh but i'm sure they
weren't thinking about it
uh you know but yeah it is what it is
dan
you know uh mr dolan and i we talked
about it
it's it's in the background um you know
all i'm
all i'm thinking about now is just doing
the best job we can do
to one get past colorado and whoever is
next
you should have worn your nick's uniform
before you played
just just so they would know how do they
not
know who you are well you know and the
second time i got
i got stopped was um i went to use the
restroom
uh and i okay i was walking back to the
locker room and because
you know all these different teams are
there there's not enough locker rooms
so what our locker rooms they made uh
you know a space right outside of the
nic
um the one the next locker room and made
it into a locker room
so i was walking back from the locker
room and the lady was like uh
i need your pass and you know first i
got upset because i'm like
you know it's in the middle of the game
and then i said miss
i'm not trying to be trying to be rude
but you see that
that picture that's you're standing
right there that's my picture right
there
so i should need a pass and anyway i'm
just going to the restroom and get back
to the locker room but you know it is
what it is dan you know when people make
mistakes you know not everybody
uh know who i am uh i understand that
i've played there along it's been a long
time since i played there
but uh it took me off then but it's in
the past
he's patrick ewing they got colorado
coming up on saturday do you remember
your first
ncaa tournament game no i don't
it has it's been so long um
i i remember a lot of them but i i don't
remember
which team or who who we played first
did you enjoy playing i know it may
sound strange but sometimes people
do things because they're really good at
it but
did you enjoy it oh i love playing
you know it's funny because you know
moving here from jamaica i didn't know
anything about basketball
you know i knew i was soccer i wanted to
be the next pele
so i knew stark and a new cricket
because you know jamaica was one color
once colonized by the british so when i
moved to america
and and started playing basketball i was
terrible at it
i was i was 12 years old i was six
eleven i mean five 11
uh you know uncoordinated uh and you
know i wasn't very good at
they would laugh at me they would tease
me you know one coach even told me that
i would never be anything
and so if i listen to those negative
negative things i wouldn't have became
the
the person that i became and the reason
why i kept playing it is because i love
this game so much i didn't i mean i
wasn't trying to be
an nba player or anything i just
realized that i love doing this thing
that much that even if i never became
great at it
i enjoyed doing it i'm not going to let
anyone stop me from doing it
how were you at soccer were you any good
at soccer
i thought i was good but i was 12.
did you ever uh talk to that coach who
said you'd never amount to anything
um i would see him when i go back when i
would go back to cambridge
i i just i just would remember it but i
just left it alone
and you know when you're trying to get
through to kids and you have kids of
your own
right do you think about what coach
thompson was doing and
you know now you're in his position
where you're trying to relate to kids
that you're a lot older then i think
you're what what 59 58 years of age or
coming up on there
yeah so i mean you you're trying to
relate to these kids
how hard is that yeah you know it's it's
a different era
um you know what coach thompson used to
do to us
um i don't think i can do now uh
you know you talk to him you know but i
do
some of the things that he did do i i
still try to do talking to them about
life after basketball
talking about talking to them about
their education talking about
you know everybody that plays college
sport their dream is to get to the nba
well here he is here i am you know i'm
i'm a person who was i've been in your
shoes
and have made it to the mountaintop
everything that you're trying to
uh try to get done i have done so i'm
gonna walk i'm a walking almanac
so ask me any questions you want and you
know i keep trying to tell them
if you want to be good at anything
anything
any walk of life if you don't put the
time in if you don't work ethic
work at this you will never be good i
don't care how much talent you have
there's been a lot of people who have
tried to make it to the nba
with all the talent in the world and it
doesn't and it don't work out
so you have to make sure that you
prepare yourself
uh who did you hear from that might
surprise us after you won on saturday
and made it into the tournament
um i heard from everyone i heard from
charles i heard from
michael uh chris mullen you know all the
other biggies coaches
um you know i was i i was expecting to
heard from barack obama or president
clinton president clinton always
reach out to me for my birthday because
he's a george he's a georgetown alum
but i was waiting for that for that call
i didn't get it
wait you didn't hear from barack obama
or bill clinton no
no i'm still waiting maybe they're
waiting for when we win it all i think
they're waiting
they're waiting until after this
saturday when when you face
colorado you should just why don't you
go into the locker room prior to
colorado and just put on highlights of
you
at georgetown just let your kids see
like
this is what basketball used to be all
about
well you know they they would probably
think i'm bragging all coaches just
bragging
you know yes you know it was funny so
uh i'm gonna tell you a quick story so
one of my one of my players
you know he came he comes to me after
practice he's like uh
i think tim eagle heffey would have
dominated you back in college
and i said really are you are you uh
what do we got come on i'm gonna have to
go get you tested right now
i said man are you crazy i i went number
one
number one overall and tim is a good is
a very good player for us
but there is no way heck that he would
have been able to dominate wait
so he he thinks one of your players
could dominate you right he was just
joking
oh okay yeah it was just joking but he
does you know we talk trash to each
other you know all day long don't you
don't you wish you you were 20 years of
age
for like 10 minutes now well i would
love to be
and i don't know about 20 but i'll say
about 25
with the type of money that they're
giving out right now
i would definitely get one of those 300
million dollar contracts
what did jordan say to you with your
text um he just wanted to congratulate
me
you know uh he and i have been friends
for so long and he
he didn't just call me after that game
after every game he would you know
either send a text or call
um you know i i want to take my hat off
to him because
he's the reason why i'm coaching you
know he gave me the opportunity to be a
coach
in in washington when he when he brought
me uh on the staff with
on doug collins staff and that's when i
fell in love with uh
love with the uh level being fell in
love with being a coach
so i want to take my hat off to him and
tell him thanks
and i i'm guessing well i'll ask you
what do you think coach thompson would
have said to you after saturday night
um you know there's a lot a lot of
different
uh things there would be some definite
profanities in here
uh but uh you know he just
say look we've come a long way they've
been like you know you're shutting
a lot of people up for not giving you an
opportunity
uh to to be a coach in the nba
um you know they think that big people
can't coach
or big people can't think but just keep
on doing the things that you're doing uh
keep on
uh working at your craft and uh that
uh that's the uh diplomatic way of of
saying it but there'd be a lot of
other things in there like he always
says he had a phd in profanity
can i get your big east tournament
credential as a souvenir
uh my biggest tournament cadential you
know what uh
i'm gonna say this is it right here
yeah there you go little champions
champions t-shirt champions t-shirt and
that is that the game ball
yes it is yes it is
you know i told the players that they
could they could play around with the
trophy
i'm taking the ball and i'm taking the
net the net is over here as well
so all of this will be going in my
office
put it in a case
and hopefully uh many more moments there
i i know you got a good recruiting class
coming in is dikembe's
dikembe mutombo's son coming into
georgetown
did you did you have to go and recruit
him did you have to go to dikembe's
house and recruit him
well unfortunately because of the covey
oh okay unable to go
there we weren't able to go to his house
since he's already signed his letter of
intent i can talk about him
uh yes he's coming um i'm looking
forward to coaching him
he'll be he's another one one of the
hoya grace
uh the next generation of the holy grace
my son
went here alonzo's son went here now the
campaign son
and i'm looking forward to the
opportunity to coach him
kick him in his butt and try to he tell
me that he's better than his dad so
i said we got a lot of work to do to get
you there what
what do you think when you see dikembe
in those geico commercials
i said it's funny as heck i said boy
the first day i met you i didn't
understand the words you were saying and
still in this damn commercial i don't
understand the word you're saying
no no no not in my house
he's such a goof ball hey congrats safe
travels have fun against uh colorado on
saturday
now i appreciate it that i'm here stuck
in my room we're here quarantining so
uh i don't have too much to do i really
appreciate it's always great to be on
your show
thank you buddy that's uh patrick ewing
they got colorado coming up on saturday